programs you've seen this weekend or any
other weekend on book tv
call one eight seven seven
on c-span for pricing information or to
request a tape
next on public lives radio host mark
cooper describes working for chilean
president salvador allende until he was
ousted by general augusto pinochet in a
1973 coup
from his book pinochet and me it's about
an hour 15 minutes
award-winning journalist mark cooper was
a translator to president allende until
the coup of 1973.
in pinochet and me he reconstructs the
tense atmosphere of the final days of
the allende government
including his hiding and subsequent
evacuation
under armed u.n protection
25 years later he returns and describes
in vivid street-level
reporting a country that is a democracy
in name only
and a society that has been transfigured
by one of the most radical armed
capitalist revolutions of our time
mark cooper's journalism has appeared in
publications such as the new yorker
harpers and rolling stone he is
currently a contributing editor of the
nation magazine as well as host of the
nationally syndicated radio nation
his previous work includes the book
rollover che guevara travels of a
radical reporter
kirkus reviews calls pinochet and me a
powerful page turner its only flaw is
its brevity
on that note please welcome mark cooper
[Applause]
i didn't bring my telephone book with me
so
we'll do is best can you can you hear me
and see me all right
uh thank you uh very much for coming out
tonight i know it's it's an
extraordinary night in portland when
it's raining and uh
thank you for uh coming to spend some
time uh this is a subject that's um
always a little bit of a mystery to me
because i've been so close to it for 30
years
it's always very difficult for me to
judge
where the interest of the audience is to
me it's an it's simple because i lived
the period of the yender government so
intensely and it was a very intense time
and the period immediately thereafter
the military coup was even more intense
even though i was only in the country of
eight days
during that military during the initial
military regime
i've been back to chile several times
i've married into a chilean family
and
i have an ongoing connection with chile
i was there as recently as uh eight or
nine days ago ten days ago
and uh so to me it's part of my life and
it's an ongoing saga
uh places like chile don't get much
attention
uh in the united states unless it's
focused through
a national security
sort of
lens
and of course with the collapse of the
cold war even that
has uh become more opaque
so uh i say all that by preface to say
that
i'm going to make a really radical
attempt to keep my remarks to
a certain economy
and then
take your questions because i'm not
really sure
where your particular interests are
uh
i i'm going to start uh with the
personal side just for a minute
because it's a question that comes up
and i'm going to get it out right right
away
and i did make an attempt uh in this
brief book
to
not tell very much of my story because
my story has some interest but it's not
very significant compared to
what is happening in chile
but the question inevitably comes up how
did a kid like you from the san fernando
valley
uh which are the flat suburbs of los
angeles how did some kid like you when
you were 20 or 21 years old wind up
being the
translator to
president allende
and that can be a very long answer or
very short answer and the very short
answer is
ronald reagan
because
in uh
that period that we're talking about
1970 or 71 70 when salvador yinde uh was
elected
that was a time when
uh ronald reagan was indeed the governor
of the state of california
i was a
20 year old college student in my second
or third year
at state university in the suburbs of
los angeles a very hot
radical
state university at the time
kind of a junior berkeley
and i was uh
very active and one of the leaders in
the local anti-war movement on the
campus
and
i got into some trouble with the
administration for this
and uh
in 1971
by executive order of the governor of
the state of california ronald reagan i
was kicked out of the state university
system in fact i was banned from any
university practically in california
and i decided that might be a good time
to pursue my education elsewhere
and
i went to chile
because i've been studying it and
because salvador allende had just been
elected and it was a very exciting
notion
and i got to chile when i was 20 years
old
and i got a job in a
state uh publishing house which was more
felicitous than it sounds
and through a series of
of circumstances that are not very
extraordinary uh
moving from one job to another within a
year i wound up being the translator to
the president
uh
when i
started doing that i was exactly 21
years old
and uh it is an extraordinary
a privilege that i had really
extraordinary an extraordinary
experience to live through what happened
in chile to have
worked with salvador allende and then to
have survived the military coup was an
extra treat
and
i
dedicate the book to ronald reagan and
it is heartfelt
because the education while i'm a big
defender of public education
uh and actually at some level defend the
state university system in california i
have to say that the education i got
in real life was better than a state
college education so this one is for the
gipper
it's not a phone book but it'll do how's
that
yeah okay
uh
it is uh it is incredibly uh
it is incredible
that we uh actually meet
today
the publisher of this book
verso publishers and i
knew when we put this book together
we knew it would come out more or less
at a time when the case of general
pinochet would be
generating some news
we did not know that it would be this
week
that it actually came to a conclusion
and it is hard you might be scrunching
your eyebrows and saying what do you
mean i read in the paper that it's kind
of like a ping-pong match
he's arrested he's not arrested he's out
of jail he's in jail he's indicted he's
not indicted
it is indeed a very complicated tale
but let me cut to the chase and tell you
that it was precisely
48 hours ago
literally 48 hours ago
on wednesday
that general pinochet was met at his
estate
by a detachment of chilean
civilian police like the fbi
accompanied by an investigating
magistrate
and pinochet was forced to sign the
papers
officially putting him under house
arrest
for the indictment that had come
early 48 hours earlier that was 96 hours
ago on monday
general pinochet was formally indicted
on
charges of the murder
kidnap disappearance
of 75 civilians in chile
75
out of more than 3 000 of course that
were murdered in chile 1100 of whom were
disappeared and whose bodies were not
found
there are
coincidentally another 225 cases pending
against general
so if he should snuggle out of this one
there's another 224
to try
but the fact of the matter is that
general pinochet has been detained it's
a little hard to follow
but he's been detained three times
he was first detained by
a international arrest warrant in
london in october 1998 issued by a
spanish court i wouldn't go into that
detail because it sounds kind of
confusing
he was held in british custody for 500
days
he was returned to chile
a year ago
and then two months ago on the first of
december
he was indicted by
the investigating judge
that indictment was overturned by the
chilean supreme court on a technicality
those technicalities were overcome
in the last two months and
specifically in the last 20 days
and the indictment that came down on
january 29th
is the real mccoy
and general pinochet is appealing that
and the best that the general can hope
for by any
informed analysis the best he can hope
for a couple of months out is that the
chilean supreme court may excuse him
from trial
for
mental reasons that he's not mentally
fit to stand trial
now parenthetically i have to say that
the best
publication in chile
is a
bi-weekly tabloid whose title is the
clinic
and for those of you who speak spanish
the title of the publication is not la
clinica
it is they actually use the english
words the clinic
and it refers to
the london clinic
in the united kingdom where general
pinochet was held and then originally
and arrested in 1998
the clinic a couple of weeks ago
ran the most brilliant
front page headline that i had seen
it was about three weeks ago that
general pinochet was
forced
to submit to mental exams
court ordered
to see if he was fit to stand trial
because chilean law says that if you're
over 70 years of age you have a right
to be examined mentally to see if you
are either by the actual words in the
code are crazy to see whether you're
local crazy or demented
and uh
and if you're crazy or demented you can
be excused from trial
and the clinic
a couple of weeks ago ran this i should
have brought it ran this beautiful a
full page uh
a headline that said really it said the
mental tests are superfluous because
only a psychopath would throw bodies
into the ocean
this came indeed
at the same time that news
uh was made
by the chilean armed forces at the
beginning of this year
that for the first time in history
uh recognized that indeed they did throw
bodies into the ocean
now all of this is prelude to
the following question
what difference does it make
is this about
revenge is this about
extracting a pound of flesh from
a rather decrepit 85 year old former
dictator when general pinochet is
bloated and he is physically diminished
and often needs a cane or a wheelchair
his speech is off he probably does
suffer some mental
degradation
what is this about
and the answer is
and this is why it's so exciting to have
this book out at this point now
the answer is that this is not
about the trial of general finishing
and indeed human rights activists in
chile recognize that there probably will
not be a trial of general pinochet
because he will probably either
be excused for mental reasons or he will
stretch this out so long he will simply
die
before the trial
that is why this week
it is really thrilling you don't see it
in the american press because the
american press is more interested
uh in the story of not a man biting dog
but dog biting woman
this week
uh if we could get one fiftieth of that
amount of coverage of world events that
we would be
very well off
this
the human rights activists in chile
declared victory
this week they consider the pinochet
case to be over
whether or not he goes to trial
because what the pinochet case was about
wasn't about putting an old man on trial
the pinochet case is about
who is going to write history
and what that history is going to be
and
what effect that has on popular
consciousness and thought
now
that still might sound like a mystery to
you so i'll take you to the next step
and say
that what is extraordinary about chile
is that if you are here tonight and you
have enough interest in this subject to
be gracious enough to come here this
evening
and you already know something about
chile you already have an association in
your head you hear the word pinochet and
it evokes certain associations
i'm going to guess
and say that those associations are
dictator
human rights abuser
murderer
torturer and all of these are true
the amazing part is that of everywhere
in the world
chile
has been the place that knows the least
about chile
the things that we assume
that everybody knows
millions of chileans didn't know
because for 17 years they lived under a
military dictatorship that did not
permit
that discussion and then in the last 10
years of democracy
this had been pushed aside
a free trade
and
a a privatized economy and a thatcherite
kind of celebration of the free market
uh was pushed on the chilean people as
values more important than understanding
their history
and chileans are pretty smart
and there's 15 million of them
i think a lot of them knew what was
going on in chile but it's the amount of
people that were in denial about this is
really striking because you think
there'd be nobody
you'd think that even the supporters of
pinochet would recognize what would
happen but would justify it would say
well yes uh 3 000 people were killed and
1100 were disappeared and 80 or 90 000
were tortured and a couple hundred
thousand were sent to exile but that's
the price you have to pay for freedom
that's not what you heard you'd hear
that no
nobody was tortured these are stories
that are made up
if people
claim they were disappeared they were
guerrillas who were killed by the
military because they were trying to
kill police officers it said it was kind
of science fiction a kind of collective
denial
the wonderful news is that the events of
the last two and a half years since the
arrest of pinochet and specifically i'm
just delighted to have been there in the
last two or three weeks a series of
events have happened in chile that have
reversed that whole course of history
what has happened in chile now is
undeniable and even the most ardent
supporters or former supporters of
pinochet are those who stuck their heads
deepest into the sand
now have to face
that reality
right
and
it is extraordinary
now i'll raise the next rhetorical
question
why is it extraordinary what difference
does it make
if people know or don't know
i'm going to use an example that's right
in our hands
because it's the best way i can
communicate this to an audience that
isn't chilling in
i'm going to
take a rough guess and assume that there
is not a preponderance of republicans
here this evening
there might be a few rockefeller
republicans but i'm going to assume
there aren't a lot of you
if you're not a republican i want you to
examine the way you felt
when george bush was elected president
or when john ashcroft
was
confirmed as attorney general
now
these men
and i need to say this uh coming out of
chile these men are not fascists they're
not
and we often use that term very loosely
but i suggest that you don't
because it is to
be disrespectful
to those who really suffer under fascism
george bush
and john ashcroft are conservatives
they're not fascists and they're not
nazis and they're not dictators and the
rule of law in the united states is
flawed
and unjust but it exists
and there's a difference between a
country governed by even
an unjust rule of law and a government
ruled by a military dictatorship and we
should never confuse the two
having said that look how bad you felt
having these jokers elected and
confirmed
and it isn't it is a feeling i know what
it feels like
you feel
a sense of
frustration
of shame or embarrassment you say this
is what my country has chosen this is
what people think this is what
we are
for example
if you understand does that make sense
to you do you understand what i'm saying
if you can sense that
then put yourself please in the role of
a chilean
who
lived through 17 years of military
dictatorship
if this chilean's
iq was above room temperature
they knew that they were living in a
authoritarian military dictatorship
where abuse was the norm
where people
were murdered and killed and raped and
tortured and it sounds like a cliche but
it's true where their bodies were
disappeared where they were thrown into
lime pits or thrown into the ocean
literally
where their
stomachs were slid open
before they were thrown out of the
helicopter so that they would sink to
the bottom of the ocean
where they were
buried uh in the desert and then ten
years later had their bones dug up and
were thrown into the ocean in case
somebody would discover the bones
imagine living through that for 17 years
having then
a complicated political process which we
could spend hours talking about a
complicated political process then takes
place where the military dictatorship
retreats
where democracy is restored
where there are indeed
fairly clean and orderly constitutional
elections
where
three succeeding civilian
administrations are elected a congress
is elected you know it's like
kansas
and
and
the government that gets elected is in
fact even a government of opponents of
pinochet and yet
and yet
seven years into that that is to say
pinochet leaves power in 1990 and in
1997
this man is still commander-in-chief of
the army
and a year later in 1998
when he retires as chief of the army
he assumes under the constitution that
he had written 20 years before
he assumes legally
constitutionally
democratically
the title and position
of unelected but but
actual
senator for life
and where he not only becomes a senator
for life that is not an honorary title
he's actually
in the senate
he is actually in line to become
president of the senate
now imagine
how you feel then
you pine for john ashcroft
you dream of george bush you might even
dream of james what at that point
because the sense
of overwhelming defeat
is precisely that it's overwhelming if
you have a brain
you go crazy you say well wait a minute
we know what this ma if you're if you're
aware you say we know who this guy is we
know what he did
the whole world knows
you may even have a relative who's
disappeared or been tortured or is in
exile or has been jailed you say
he's the senator
and there's an amnesty
in place that he put before he left
and not only can he not be prosecuted
but we have to call him senator
and all of his friends and all of his
cohorts and all of his accomplices and
all of his supporters are also senators
and deputies and
the director of the chamber of commerce
and whatever
imagine the sort of
collective psychological
trauma
that's inflicted upon you as a thinking
individual and then magnify that by
millions and you have a society that's
in very
big
uh trouble
because you are in absolute denial of
your history
and if you are in absolute denial of
your history then you have no idea who
you are in the present and you have even
less of a clue where you're going
and it is a bad feeling
let me just say in passing chile today
has the highest today has the highest
index
of depression
and of psychological problems among the
population of any country in the
hemisphere there's a reason
this is a country that is reasonably
well off by south american standards
this is not a banana republic
you know
very europeanized country
everybody's depressed
you would be depressed too
the incredible thing that happened
was that the mistake that mr pinochet
committed
was that after having evolved and
developed a relationship with baroness
maggie thatcher
he decided on one too many visits to
london
and in 1998
he went there to do some shopping
and he went there
to visit margaret thatcher
and the poor guy actually went there on
a public relations offensive
he actually uh his family decided it was
time to improve his image and they
granted an interview to the new yorker
and they thought they were going to
rehabilitate this guy's image or buck it
up because after all he was now the
senator for life
he was a respected uh old gentleman
and there is a wonderful
salty old
latin american correspondent uh
british irish descent named hugh
o'shaughnessy
who's written a wonderful book called
the politics pinochet the politics of
torture
and hugh lived in chile as i did at the
same time
and
he wrote
what we call a polemical op-ed piece for
those of you who are journalists who
read op-ed pieces you know frequently
op-ed pieces are polemical they make a
call for something you know it's not
really going to happen but you make a
call
and
it became public in october of 1998 that
general pinochet was in london
and hugh o'shaughnessy wrote a column in
the guardian
on october 15th i believe
and the title of that column was a
murderer in our midst
and he said this
general was among us
he was here in london
and he should be arrested for murder
now i know hugh o'shaughnessy
and i know that when hugh wrote that
column
he never dreamed in his wildest dreams
that that would actually take place
within 24 hours
but it did
because some dutiful clerk
uh in scotland yard and we don't know
who it was i don't know who it was and
i've never read any article saying who
it was but some dutiful clerk received a
cabled message
from interpol it sounds like a sherlock
holmes movie
he got a cable a red alert
a red warrant
from interpol
transmitted from the spanish courts
from a judge named balthasar garcon
and judge garcon sitting in madrid
teletyped or tabled this
request over to scotland yard and said
we have an arrest warrant for general
pinochet
britain and spain are signatories to the
same treaty
against torture
you are obligated to arrest this man and
this
dutiful british clerk
much
to the chagrin
of prime minister tony blair
i assure you
said well this all looks in order
and
sent out a detachment of plainclothes
metropolitan police
known in the movies as the bobbies
and they showed up at the london clinic
and they disarmed general pinochet's
bodyguards
and
pause
they placed him under arrest
poor tony blair
the next morning
leader of the
labor government
and uh
the united kingdom had to say how
wonderful this was
that they had captured this
international war criminal i'm sure he
immediately retreated behind the cameras
and met with his advisors and said now
what are we going to do
and poor general pinochet was trapped
and all i can tell you is
that
that was a magic moment it was the magic
moment for me it was a magic moment for
every chilean i know and it was chile is
a land of earthquakes and i want to tell
you this was about a 10.1 earthquake on
the richter scale
because general pinochet had built
a regime an institutionality in a
political establishment had built that
just
plain assumed that he
was untouchable
and it is you can look for all the
similes you want you can look for all
the allegories and fables that you want
and all of the literary phrases that you
want but the best one is that the
emperor had no clothes
that was as simple as that the man who
was walking around in in in armor
impenetrable armor had it taken off by
these very polite
bobbies
and
it came at a time where you can't put
your finger on it
but all you can say
is that it was a political earthquake
and the earthquake shook loose
what had gelled over in chile
i was in chile just a few months before
general pinochet's arrest
and
to
be crass about it it's probably the best
part of my book
it's the part that i think is the best
where i actually describe what chile was
like three years ago right before
pinochet was arrested and i wrote it at
the time so i didn't know he was going
to be arrested i never dreamed he was
going to be arrested
and in that piece i generally i
essentially conceded the victory to
general pinochet
and said you won
25 years later you're the man
you have prevailed
you know
and
how wonderful it was to be wrong
and
how wonderful it was to see those
artifices crumble now the the story of
the crumbling is very complicated
and
and i could not possibly explain it to
you other than to say
at the risk of
being a little self-serving i will tell
you this that
a week from
uh today
next friday
i will have a cover piece in the nation
magazine that actually explains what
happened in the last two or three weeks
it's very complicated but the last two
or three weeks have been the final
de numan it's really been the final
unraveling because the real beauty here
i'm going to wrap up these remarks here
the real beauty here is not only that
this happened not only has
all of the
filth
and all of the horror and all of the
truth
come out
not only that
but
that in itself is good
but it's even better
because it comes
at a time
when the chilean military
and even the chilean government
made
an
extraordinary
effort
to make sure it didn't happen
it didn't just happen in a void like
everybody had forgotten it happened
against a background where 25 years
later 27 years later
the chilean military and the chilean
government unfortunately
was doing its best
to make sure that this was just off the
agenda and the wonderful part
is that beginning about the time that
pinochet got arrested
and especially after general finisher
got arrested
the game plan of the chilean military
and the game plan of the chilean
government
was to lay the groundwork so that a a
law could be passed in chile
that in spanish would be called a punto
final or a full stop
and they did this in uruguay for example
this would be a law that would
essentially just shut down
human rights cases
and it has completely
totally
and irretrievably flopped
not only flopped but it has now become
impossible in the foreseeable future
two and a half years ago there were
exactly two or three chileans in jail
for human rights
problems
they were in jail mostly because of the
of the orlando lately murder in
washington and special arrangement with
the united states
allowed these couple of guys to be
prosecuted nobody else
today
there are eight generals under
indictment
nine
if we count general pinochet
nine generals a couple of them active
duty generals
there's another 80
current and mil and former military
officers under indictment
and i read just yesterday in the chilean
press that the human rights lawyers have
another hundred cases
ready to file this week against an equal
number of military officers
it is
uh
costa governors made a film about chile
called missing
but he inadvertently made another film
about chile called zee
which i don't know if anybody is old
enough here to have seen but it's a
story about the the military
regime in greece and it does not have a
happy ending but there is a moment
of triumph in that film where there's
literally a parade
of military officers being ushered in to
be indicted by a very industrious
and committed investigating magistrate
and that is exactly where we're at in
chile they have to stand in line now to
be indicted
so i'll be glad to uh to take your
questions on any specifics or or
and
we're going to give a moment before you
speak up to make sure the microphone
gets in front of your face are there any
questions
we have one right up here
in front
could you address the death of indy i
read several different versions of it uh
and could you go into that a little bit
please uh the question is uh could i say
something about the death of salvadorian
himself
that has been an area of controversy
since he died in the
moneta palace in september of 1973.
since the coup
i have come to be i've come to be
friends and neighbors
with one of uh salvador allende's
personal doctors
who was in the moneta at the time and
the palace at the time he's a good
friend of mine now i didn't know him at
the time we worked in the same place but
i never met him
and uh
from what he has told me and from what
uh i pieced together and i think what
allende's
supporters uh have accepted
at this point i i do believe that
salvadorian killed himself
um that was the version that originally
was circulated and of course uh as long
as the military government was saying it
i mean there was a time where general
pinochet could stand up and say well
that that's white and if he said it was
white then anybody with a brain would
say it
looks white but it couldn't be white
because general pinochet is saying it's
white
there was a good amount of disbelief
about it i think that uh the the
evidence that is there is fairly
compelling that um
uh that uh on that morning of september
11 1973 and it is well documented in the
book
the armed forces rose up
they took over everything they could
they
suspended the constitution they
told all the radio and tv stations to
lock into the military network or their
antennas would be
bombed
by aircraft
they bombed
with british hawker hunter jets and the
brits have repaid the debt now but
using british jets hawker hunter jets
they bombed the presidential palace it
was on fire uh general pin uh president
allende was in the palace uh with uh
some of his supporters uh
there's a wonderful photograph that is
the last picture of salvador allende
with a military helmet on and
with ak-47
in hand and he did fight
and he did fight the
the
encroaching military
and the documentation that exists uh
would suggest that uh as the palace was
burning and as general pinochet's troops
a company which is roughly 100 troops
entered the palace and as they were
advancing toward the room he was in
he took his life
and
that's it next question
everyone back there
i would add that while we're waiting for
the microphone to get up there i think
that
it was pretty much of uh
i don't think that salvadorian could
imagine himself being prisoner to these
folks
and uh i don't think these folks could
imagine salvador allende being his their
prisoner either so i think
i don't want to reduce the gesture i
think it was a heroic gesture i don't
know if i
certainly would have had the strength
or the conviction that it takes to make
that kind of dramatic decision
but i think it that would have been the
end result in any case and i think
salvador and he knew that
yeah i was very pleased when garcon
balthazar garcon
brought the case that actually had had
pinochet arrested but i wanted to ask
you there's been a lot of debate about
how this actually came down and one of
the criticisms from
people in spain
is that
sure it's easy to
arrest and try
fascists in chile but of course
in spain there are a lot of fascists who
are still around from the franco regime
who and there hasn't been that similar
sort of situation
or accountability in spain the other
criticism which one read in the new york
times and so i guess it's somewhat
suspect and i wasn't in chile but the
question about
chileans arguing that the whole arrest
of pinochet
opened up the wounds and sort of made
reconciliation more difficult so
if you could just comment on that those
are two very incisive questions
uh and i'll take them one by one and if
i forget the second one remind me the
first question was uh isn't there a
certain hypocrisy
if you will among the spanish to go
around inducting chilean fascists and
not doing anything about franco's
fascists
uh let's deal with that question first
uh it's an imperfect world
and
i think that's an argument to be made
but i don't think that's the fault of
judge garcon that is the political that
is a political institutional problem in
spain judge garcon
uh is quite an extraordinary individual
he was
appointed as kind of a super judge
by the
end quotes former spanish socialist
government of felipe gonzalez earlier in
the decade or the late 80s
very
conservative government
and
judge garcon though appointed by this
government
immediately set about to indict just
about everybody in the government
on corruption charges and drug charges
and he is
quite a modern hero
not only that he looks like a movie star
and
he's about as perfect as you get as a
character and somebody will make a film
about judge carson
judge garcon after he wiped out his own
government
decided that he would look into the
deaths of 300
spaniards
300 spanish citizens
who died
in chile and argentina principally
during the dictatorships of the 1970s
and 80s that's a lot of spaniards
and
judge garcon unraveled
the
network and i i i'm not a conspiracy
freak so
i want to underline that it sounds like
a
a bad movie but he unraveled what is
known as operation condor
it sounds like a robert redford movie
that was three days of the condor
operation condor was a real thing run by
the military dictatorships of chile
bolivia argentina uruguay
and
some elements of the united states
intelligence services
in the 1970s and 80s and it was a
network of repression
it was a way that uh if a chilean fled
to argentina
they could be killed and disappeared in
argentina and if an argentine and in
argentine fled
chile fled argentina wound up in chile
or bolivia they could be eliminated
there and it was in fact operation
condor it was a an act of operation
condor that led to the murder in the
united states of orlando lately
and it was operation condor that led to
the murder of a army general of former
army general chilean army general
pratt's and buenos aires
judge garcon unraveled all of that
and all i can say is
god bless him
uh
your second question was a good one it's
about the question of whether
it's better for pinochet to be tried in
chile or whether it opened up the wounds
to begin this is wonderful uh this was a
the second question is uh how do what
how to respond to the notion that uh
judge garcon's arrest of general
pinochet in 1998 just opened up old
wounds
and made reconciliation among chileans
uh more difficult this was the operative
uh excuse the line this was the
political line of pinochet's defenders
and in a nauseating sense i
i
i i like as a journalist and as a writer
i like to be inventive in my
in enrich in my use of adjectives but i
have every time i come back to this
point i always use the word nauseating i
can't think of a better one the
nauseating attitude of the chilean
government
because the chilean government
composed
composed of pinochet's opponents the
moment that this criminal was detained
in
uh
london the chilean government got on its
knees and begged for his release
you really have to be
i can explain that but we don't have
enough time i mean you have to really
understand chile to understand what's
wrong with this chilean government that
it would do that but nevertheless that
was the line
well it's for you to decide if you
believe that you can reconciliate while
murderers and torturers walk free
while they are elected to the congress
while they become senators while they
run radio and tv stations while they're
your neighbor
then i suppose that's right
but i think it's a ludicrous notion
i know that was the line but being in
chile at the time was there any popular
sentiment
for that maybe because people were in
denial or was it just a line from the
government that's a very good question
the question was might be ludicrous but
did people adhere to that idea and was
there actually support for that idea in
chile at the time the answer is
absolutely yes
for several reasons there was uh you
know there's 15 or 20 percent of that
chilean population that is always going
to be pro pinishing
why because they have extraordinary
class
consciousness uh and they make no bones
about it
no pun intended
they uh
they are proud of it and they are
forever grateful for general pinochet
for imposing their class interests at
the point of bayonet and they will more
or less tell you that
that's relatively small
uh relatively a little bit bigger than
it should be
and then you have people who are victims
of the denial who you know like in our
country walk around in a somnolent state
all day repeating you know cliches
and i think there was a fear
and it was an unwarranted fear because
there was no physical reason to be
afraid but there was a reflex to be
afraid
because after 25 years of being
you know there was 17 years where you
could disappear if you took the man's
name in vain
right
and then there was 10 more years where
it wasn't really legal to do that and it
didn't really happen but it felt like it
so there was a certain amount of
disbelief
and i have to say in passing in case the
chilean consulate is listening
that even today
the situation that i described to you
which is a positive situation
is not one that is even
opportunistically capitalized upon by
the chilean government even today
they will not really latch on to this
even though from crude political
calculation you could i'm really talking
now about crude calculations you can
show one poll after another in chile
where there is an overwhelming consensus
the new york times sometimes uh fudges
this and says well chile's divided well
divided there's all sorts of divisions
right there's
50 50 and there's 70 30. that's also
divided 80 20 is also a division right
there is an overwhelming consensus in
chile
depends how you ask the question
sixty percent seventy percent sixty five
percent seventy two percent eighty
percent that justice should be done in
some sense
the chilean government refuses to
mobilize that politically
so you have an extraordinary political
situation
where
two-thirds of the country is clearly
that's a big majority in political terms
there are few political issues where you
get 65 percent
you have a landslide majority of
two-thirds
who is for justice
and then when elections come in the last
year
the right is able to come within a half
a percentage point of winning the
election
and the right in chile traditionally
never got more than 30 35 percent of the
vote
right
and somehow at the very moment when
general pinochet is at his lowest
when his whole political legacy is in
tatters
where in fact the right in chile has as
well as its could as well as
capable has begun to turn its back on
him and at least ignore him at the
moment where they are most politically
bankrupt
they are an electoral ascendancy
and the reason they are in electoral
ascendancy and we are privileged as
americans because we can understand this
is that the average chilean can't tell
the difference
between the right-wing coalition
the old pinochet forces
and the ruling center-left coalition
because the differences between them are
roughly the differences between
republicans and democrats
and
people look at it and the government
gives no voice
to this anti-pinochet sentiment if the
government gave voice to the
anti-pinochet sentiment it would
mobilize hundreds of thousands of people
in cleveland electoral majority the
problem is it would anger to economic
elites in chile with whom it has to do
business
so it is a perfectly sordid situation
while we're waiting for that question
let me also tell you that there are
parliamentary elections coming up this
year and it's very likely that the right
wing will win them
in spite of all of this
i was very impressed with christopher
hitchens article in the last harpers
that seems to make
a real case that kissinger was
guilty of being a war criminal in the
sense of the death of general schneider
and the the coup in chile and i wonder
what your views on that issue were
the question is uh
that recently my colleague from the
nation magazine christopher hitchens
writing in a different magazine writing
in harpers
holds
former secretary of state and national
security adviser henry kissinger
responsible
for the deaths of
chileans and for
his role in the coup in chile thank you
for asking my favorite question
i'm sorry come so late in the
presentation because i could spend hours
talking about mr kissinger
christopher hitchens book
the trial of
henry kissinger
proudly published by my same publisher
versa will be available later this
spring
in which
mr kissinger in which christopher
hitchens indicts
henry kissinger and he indicts him
on vietnam
on cambodia and on chile
i've just finished reading another fine
book called our vietnam by jack length
uh which doesn't set out to indict henry
kissinger but it sure does
for vietnam
look the nixon in kiss nixon the nixon
administration openly plotted against
uh
the agenda government this is no secret
except to some chileans uh and even that
was in a documentary in chile a couple
months ago for the first time
the nixon government applauded against
allende we now have a release of
documents there's another important book
coming out
later this year by peter cornblue which
will be a collection of the
recently declassified u.s documents on
chile we've always known the united
states had some involvement now we know
more we know
some of the sums of money that were paid
we know
that millions of dollars were given to
the opposition in chile to the peninsula
forces we know that the central
intelligence agency as you pointed out
dealt directly with fascist groups in
chile that wound up assassinating the
commander-in-chief of the army
we know that the central intelligence
agency had some knowledge perhaps some
participation in operation condor
we know that there is some pretty smelly
uh connections i'm not being suggestive
here i mean they're very complicated but
we know that there are some uh levels of
knowledge and perhaps operational
responsibility of the
cia
in the actual murder of lately air
and we know that kissinger oversaw this
general policy
i do not think that gen
general i do not think that mr kissinger
will be indicted
in the united states of america
i know that he will be indicted by
christopher hitchens and that's probably
a worse fate than being indicted by a
court
he will be indicted by christopher in
this book
and
you know i'm not and i do know that
christopher's intent actually in writing
this book is to actually provide the
legal brief
for
mr kissinger to be indicted in the
international court of justice at the
hague
now this has happened before you know
the united states was convicted
in the international court of justice in
the hague in the 1980s for its
activities in nicaragua
at that point the reagan administration
decided it wasn't going to recognize the
international court of justice and
nothing happened so i'm not expecting mr
kissinger to do any time in jail
if you'll allow me though i would love
to tell you my favorite uh anecdote that
has come out in the last year about
henry kissinger because it is just too
wonderful
it is just too embarrassing and too
delicious
a couple of years ago and fortunately i
can't remember the official title
of the book
and i wouldn't plug it if i did but
henry kissinger came out with the second
volume of his memoirs
and in those memoirs he characterizes
the
one face-to-face meeting that he had
with general pinochet
and he had one face-to-face meeting with
pinochet
in the spring of 1976
in santiago
and this was at the height of the
bloodletting let me only say this was in
the middle of the frenzy
there was literally blood on the walls
and in his memoirs
uh
henry kissinger says and i'm
paraphrasing
so don't hold me to the exact quote
but henry kissinger said essentially
that he told
general pinochet he expressed to general
pinochet the overall concern
that the united states government had
about possible human rights violations
and excesses
of authority and told general pinochet
that he should be more attentive to
these things and let him know that the
united states government was looking
over his shoulder
that's all well and fine there's only
one problem and that is about a year and
a half ago
with
the at the gerald ford uh presidential
library in grand rapids michigan
uh
the some of the ford administration
papers were declassified and made public
and among those
papers
was the actual transcript
of the meeting
between mr kissinger
and mr
finisher
this is not conjecture this is the
official u.s government record
of that meeting
and
it's now been a year and a half since
i've read it and i have to be honest
with you and i can't remember
if the transcript was a verbatim
transcript
i believe it was
or if it was a paraphrased transcript
but nevertheless it's the official
record as taken down by state department
stenographers
and in that meeting
mr kissinger says to mr finisher the
exact opposite
this
i'm going to withhold my adjectives this
functionary of the united states
government mr kissinger looks at general
pinochet and he asks
he begs an apology
and he apologizes to general pinochet
for the contentious statements that have
recently come out of the united states
congress
who's been upset
about people being murdered and killed
and a general again
mr kissinger says to general pinochet
essentially
don't pay any attention to that
we support you fully
more
horrifying
and i refer you you can actually see
this online so i'm not i don't want to
be quoted directly and
i don't want i don't want to
characterize this improperly and you
should check this out yourself if you go
online and you search for the national
security archives which is actually a
non-profit
organization that declassifies documents
you will see these documents online and
you can make your own judgment and you
can get the exact quotes but worse
at that meeting
general pinochet complains
he complains
to kissinger about the behavior of
orlando lately
a former
ambassador from salvador yende's
government a chilean leftist who at that
time was living in exile in washington
and had become the chief lobbyist
against the military regime he was
lobbying the imf in the world bank to
not provide multilateral funding for
pinochet and he was lobbing against u.s
support for pinochet and pinochet loudly
complains
to henry kissinger
about
orlando lately and henry kissinger
essentially says nothing
and of course it is three months later
that
uh general pinochet eliminates
orlando lately with a car bomb in the
middle of downtown washington
so uh it is an excellent question that
you ask uh
the kissinger himself and the ford
administration are up to their in the
nixon administration primarily are are
up to their neck in
this and uh we know a lot about it but
uh justice is often slow and elusive
you have a question over here
i think maybe we'll take two more
questions because i think we're running
out of time yes my question is about um
the years 1998 when
i
i felt at the time also i completely
agree with you that people were
and the whole
news that was coming out of the country
was that
chileans were very
unsupportive of
spain's position that they'd taken on
arresting pinochet and
they
you know wanted their hero to to live
free and have you know a happy rest of
his life
but i
and and then two years later in the year
2000 correct when lagos was elected who
is the current president and socialist
yeah i
how what's your perception of that
and and i know that lagos is no
in the area
the question is how is it possible that
in 1998 it seemed that most or many
chileans were actually
supporting pinochet when he was arrested
in london and only two years later a
socialist
opponent is elected as president
and how polarized is the country uh
it is a good question but it it relies
on perceptions that are not
fully accurate uh
it is not true that in 1998 most
chileans thought that there was some
injustice committed by general
pinochet's arrest
what there was is there was a very small
but very noisy and very
exercised minority that took to the
streets right
and chile is one of the few countries
where rich people come out and
demonstrate in the streets it's really
quite a spectacle
it is really extraordinary i have been
in front of general pinochet's house
unfortunately twice
over the years on his birth date and it
is one of the most surreal experiences
you could ever see in your life uh and
it reveals all of one's prejudices
because i admit freely to my prejudices
chile is i'm going to answer your
question a chili chili chili is a third
world country uh regardless of some of
its protestations it is a poor country
and half the country lives at or near
poverty uh and uh uh half of the country
doesn't and the people who are
comfortable are very comfortable and
there's even a racial divide that nobody
talks about it's very much an apartheid
society and uh the ruling elites are
lily white and european
and uh most the rest the population is
is darker complected and mixed you know
not a lot of indian or indigenous blood
but enough to to dilute the gene pool
uh from the from the rich neighborhoods
and as an american no matter what it is
i'm not gonna ascribe this to you i'm
going to speak for personal title i
freely admit my prejudices and when you
go and you're among the rich people they
look more like people i know i mean you
know they're better dressed and they're
uh better groomed and you know they have
real suits and ties on and expensive
glass frames and their nails are
manicured and they have on colorful uh
sort of uh
lards or
woody bandanas and or and and there's
kind of an assumption maybe you look at
them say oh well these look like the
folks you'd see uh you know around
harvard or
uh you know berkeley or stanford and
it's true you you would uh in fact most
of these folks did go to harvard or
stanford or something like that and and
and i freely admit to my bias that you
figure that richer better educated
people well they're a little bit less to
less prone to excitability and outbursts
etc and yet
you go and these are the folks who are
outside of general pinochet's door
jumping up and down and dancing to
german
marching hymns literally you know and
bowing and thanking him and saying oh
please thank you thank you so much for
killing all these people in our defense
i mean that's a simplification but it is
extraordinary
these are the people who took to the
streets
when general pinochet was arrested it
was the upper middle class came out in
the streets and tried to sack the
british and spanish embassies
it was really an extraordinary
moment and the
the spanish embassy is located in a in a
rich suburb
of santiago and the mayor of that suburb
is a former military colonel colonel
labay big supporter general pinochet and
as soon as general pinochet was arrested
mayor labay cut off garbage services to
the spanish embassy so they'd have to
rot in their garbage
uh
so uh the
reporters love this i mean this is real
fodder for reporters because you go out
and there's a thousand or two thousand
people in the street but that's all
there was
there was a small minority couple
thousand people who were
i'm sorry but they're hysterical and
they're just hysterical
and uh
these are people i have interviewed
colonel lebaye and i interviewed colonel
labay in 1998 and uh i'll be perfectly
frank when i interviewed him i
i
i didn't let him know that i was a
former translator to salvador allende
and uh
he was very diffident towards me very
off-putting and and i realized in the
course interview that he was
he didn't like me and the reason he
didn't like me now this is going to be a
trip for you the reason he didn't like
me is because i was an american
and according to him the american
government has just been so outrageously
left-wing
and it's criticisms of chile that's just
part of some
international socialist conspiracy to in
to disfigure the history of the noble
chilean military regime so he actually
looks upon americans as the american
government is left-wing meddlers and
this is the kind of now we're getting
into fascism yeah now we're going way
beyond john ashcroft and gail norton
we're way on the other side right
so uh
the answer to you is that there was only
a small and noisy minority the
incredible part
is
i hate to quote richard nixon there was
a huge silent majority in favor of
pinochet being
arrested but you see the chilean
civilian government
that is putatively socialists and
christian democrats as the opponents of
pinochet
they were begging for pinochet's release
so you had an extreme right and a right
politically
on that issue
right so if you were a well-thinking
chilean and i go back to what i said an
hour ago where you're into this kind of
collective psycho psychotic denial
imagine what you felt like then
here that guy finally gets arrested
and
the chilean government that is composed
in part by the socialist party which was
salvador allende's party
and there were actually people in the
government including
the current president of chile lagos who
had to go into exile
and there are other lower level
functionaries the chilean government who
were arrested and tortured
they're on the telephone asking the
foreign minister the foreign secretary
of great of of the united kingdom to
release the dictator
it really is too rich for words it
really is nauseating so there was no
political mobilization around that which
then explains your second question
second question was how did the
socialists get elected
against this background last year uh the
socialist who got elected ricardo lagos
is actually the government candidate
this this is a governing coalition of
christian democrats and socialists for
the last 10 years the socialists have
been in the government as junior
partners for the last 10 years and now
as a matter of political patronage of
sorts so there was also a primary but it
was pretty much cooked
behind the scenes it was now the turn of
the socialists to lead this government
but these socialists
in chile are
and i am no
fervent supporter of the former clinton
gore administration i can tell you that
uh but the clinton gore administration
are like you know 60s radicals
compared to
the chilean socialists chile is a place
where there is no
legal divorce
and where the socialists have not done
anything about it it's a country where
there is no
therapeutic abortion
period
for any cause
and there are women in jail not for
providing abortion but for having an
abortion so we're not talking about a
particularly enlightened
or progressive
regime let's take one more question and
i can talk to you uh separately
yes
what about john ashcroft and our in our
denial about the latoya case i
understand that janet reno was close to
issuing indictments
and what's going to happen now what do
you what do you think about that that is
such a great question to end on thank
you for asking the question
uh the question is
what about john ashcroft what about the
justice department what about our own
collective denial isn't it true that
attorney general reno was on the verge
of indicting general pinochet
i'll give you the five-minute answer and
we'll be done
uh
it is uh
it's been it's been um i i feel
privileged to live through this because
um
it is always great to go into the middle
of middle age and have a lot of your
assumptions challenged
uh
i can tell you uh with absolute
certainty
and i know it is difficult to believe
but
it is true
that there are
there were
as of january 20th
um
career
uh
prosecutors in the united states
department of justice and that there are
in fact federal investigators better
known as fbi agents
who
really do
honestly
want to indict
general pinochet
for his role in the murder of orlando
lately
in washington dc in 1976 and there is no
statute of limitations on murder
and
i don't have to even speculate it a
certain i know that for a fact you don't
have to take my word
for the following
point because it's a public record
uh back
in
august of last year
the united states justice department
sent
a a
a official uh
um
list of sent to the chilean
courts a list of 42 people
that the justice department wanted to
interview better known as question
in relation to this case it took the
chilean government several months to
respond
actually was a year and a half ago and
then
late last year the chilean government
relented and
the united states justice department
investigators were in chile
uh last year
and under the and the compromise that
was made is that the chileans didn't let
the americans do the questioning but the
chilean magistrates question 42 suspects
in the presence
of these u.s
uh investigators or at least gave the
transcripts to them so that is to say
that 40 some odd people in chile were
questioned as recently as last year by
the united states justice department
investigating the death of lately
it is true
that
there was a debate inside the justice
department and there was some indication
that the clinton administration or the
reno justice department however you want
to put it
was going to indict general pinochet
uh
we now have a transition and john
ashcroft is attorney general
uh
i'm going to say that i don't know i
wouldn't rule it out
i wouldn't rule it out i don't think we
should be blind about that i think that
sometimes you know
tony blair didn't want general pinochet
to get arrested but he got arrested
because there's a certain independence
of the
you know as as as cooked as we think the
system is there's all these
little margins of space that you that
honest people can operate in
some of these investigators in the
justice department are career
prosecutors and they're still there
so
i wouldn't rule out uh an indictment by
the united states what i would say is i
actually think it isn't the uh bush
administration that is the biggest
impediment
to the
possible indictment i'd say that
fortuitously or otherwise probably some
of the steam
to indict finishing united states
has been lessened because he's actually
been indicted in chile
and there may be a notion of well it's
overkill at this point you know
we would love to see the indictment
we would love to see the indictment
at this point
the united states
i'll just say in closing one of the
more of horrendous
acts that the clinton administration
carried out in its final days
uh
you know you he got
mr clinton got a lot of deservedly bad
press for the mark rich pardon etc but
one of uh much more significant than
that
and virtually it was in the new york
times in one article
but unremarked was that in late december
the clinton administration approved the
sale of a dozen f-16 fighter jets to
chile
that chile does not need and that the
region doesn't need
and it's
two things at play there one
this is the lagos government gift
to the chilean military
uh you know where some of you are
getting indicted but don't feel bad
here's a fleet of new fighter jets
uh that cost a billion dollars that
chile can't really afford
um
the dastardly part of this by the
clinton administration is that this
breaks
a 20-year
freeze on the introduction of
sophisticated weaponry into the region
so uh you know even the bush
administration didn't do this the old
bush administration even they respected
that ban
and these guys clinton and gore
went ahead and uh
said well it's okay we're leaving office
have some fighter jets
so right now there's that deal pending
and then more importantly the united
states is currently began under clinton
last month and is now continuing the
united states is now negotiating a free
trade agreement with chile
as uh the uh
first step in what it hopes is the free
trade area of the americas
so
that may there may be a political
calculation
made in any
ruffling of the feathers so i would have
to say that you know the chances of the
united states indicting general pinochet
are diminishing
quickly i want to thank all of you it's
been really a great discussion i
encourage you to buy the book i'll be
glad to sign it and
you know we can chat then thanks so much
for uh great attention thank you
[Applause]
mark cooper is a radio host and a former
translator for former chilean president
salvador allende until he was ousted by
general augusta pinochet in a 1973 coup
his book pinochet and me is published by
verso visit them online at
versobooks.com
public lives can be seen twice every
weekend here on c-span too saturdays at
8pm and sundays at 11 p.m eastern